I'll be showing you how we use Claude
code SEO to run this website that gets
over 80,000 users every single month.
Our first Claude code SEO skill that we
use allows us to write up-to-date,
trendy,
um, news articles or topics within the
niche of our website every single day.
So, here is the actual, uh, prompt or
the skill that you can use. If you want
to get access to these skills, just
comment SEO and I'll send it over to
you. But, if you take a look at these
skills, these are routine. So,
essentially, every single day at a time
that you set, the AI will go out, it
will do a research based upon your
niche, based based upon what's trending
in Google Trends, and we actually use
live, up-to-date Google Trends data, and
um, Google News articles, and it will
find an article that is going to be
suitable for your niche, for your
audience, and it's going to bring you in
some new traffic every single day. So,
this is really, really powerful because
it's fresh, up-to-date information that
is less competitive because not everyone
is going to be able to write in these
topics as quickly as you are. And, as
you can see here, it writes it it does
the research on the topics, and then it
uses our connection with WordRocket.
WordRocket is an AI, uh, SEO writing
tool. So, we see here it loads
WordRocket to generate the article
because if we use Claude to generate our
articles every single day, we can run
into usage limits very, very quickly,
and WordRocket is already optimized to
write content with internal linking and
in your brand voice, and so on, and so
forth. And then, it'll go ahead and post
this article directly over to your
website. So, we see here that this
article was written and posted directly
over to our website. And, this is done
every single day on autopilot with
Claude, and we do this for not just one,
but a couple of our websites here. So,
again, if you go ahead and take a look
at the second article, we take a look at
the live URL, it did the exact same
process. And, as you can see here, we
have a nice article here with beautiful
images.
And this is a very unique article on
up-to-date content. That's the first way
that we use Claude code. The second way
that we use Claude code is if we find a
keyword that we really like and we want
to write on, we use the SERP to publish
article. So essentially, what this does
is we give Claude a keyword and then
it'll go out, it will do competitive
research on the SERP overview for that
specific keyword to see what the SERP
looks like, what is the structure of the
articles that are ranking or the types
of articles that are ranking, a
competitive analysis of our actual
competitors and it'll give you all that
information back and based upon the
information that it found, it will then
write a better article on that keyword
to increase the likeness that you'll
actually outrank your competitors.
Another Claude SEO skill that we use is
a backlink opportunities finder. So
essentially, what this is going to do is
going to find and do competitive
research and then find ways in which you
can get backlinks from places that have
linked to your competitors or places
that have mentioned your brand online
but haven't linked back to your um to
your website. So for example, the brand
mention backlinks. This will find where
places that people have mentioned your
website but haven't actually included a
link to give you a high chance of you
getting links. If you're more of a local
SEO, we have the local SEO skill which
is a full stack local SEO skill that
audits a local's business SEO, builds a
local SEO strategy, and creates landing
pages and so on and so forth. If you're
now starting to do research on a website
or building out your site, we also have
the ultimate SEO and the SEO audit
skills that will do complete SEO audit
based upon your competitors and give you
give you actionable insights of how to
start and grow your website. So those
are some of the skills that we use to
grow our websites to 80,000 users and
beyond. If you want to get access to
these skills, just comment SEO below and
I'll send it over to you. Also, if you
want to try out Word Word for yourself,
it is the best AI content writing tool
in the market. It allows you to write
SEO and GO optimized articles. I'll
leave a link for Word Rocket in the
comments below. Take care.